it is one of those companies where
there's lots of of improv going on I'm
guessing there's lots of improv going on
which you both enjoyed yeah I mean any
especially she enjoys when I like insult
her
it's true yeah you're really good at it
she said very easy to insult I mean I
don't know it's just something about
your sincerity or something you know
what I'm not gonna argue it that I know
my favorite is when you called me an
animatronic on that day you
really look like you called me a big 2/3
Russell Crowe story rebels like Annie
called me a big tater isochronous
what did I make up you did
I like are you watching me from there
really
[Music]
you